iowa es un gran estado ayudar a los
vecinos está en nuestro adn desde el
campesino que tiene necesidades hasta la
madre que pierde su empleo y que tiene
también dificultades la comunidad nos
ayuda a salir adelante pero qué ocurre
cuando pasa una tormenta porque destruye
todo el estado cuando no es un campesino
el que ha perdido su cultivo sino
cientos cuando no es un vecino en
problemas sino que son miles los que no
tienen comida eso pasó un huracán pasó
con vientos fuertes y acabó con tres
enteros de pierda dejó a miles sin
electricidad y destruyó hogares y dejó
devastación en su paso fue la peor
tormenta en la historia del estado y lo
que que hicieron las personas de iowa
fue lo que esperarán se cuidaron unos a
otros y aún lo hacen pero alguien más
nos apoyó nuestro presidente cuando los
vientos habían pasado él apareció tal
vez no puedan saberlo porque los medios
no lo reportaron pero la administración
ya estuvo aquí con toda su fuerza
después de la tormenta el presidente
llamó para asegurarme que teníamos todo
el apoyo del gobierno federal y más
adelante esta semana el vicepresidente
pence vino a agua para de nuevo
asegurarnos que el presidente y su
administración estaban con nosotros con
la ayuda de la administración son
rápidamente recibimos una declaración de
desastre que
ayudará a ponernos de pie nuevamente el
presidente acabó con la burocracia para
que se hiciera lo que tenía que hacerse
de manera rápida pero esa no es la
primera vez que el presidente camps le
mostró a la gente de iowa que podíamos
contar con él en 2019 cuando las
inundaciones que devastaron las
comunidades tanto grandes como pequeñas
a lo largo del río missouri en iowa
nebraska y misurí el presidente aprobó
nuestra petición de ayuda en un tiempo
récord en dos días bueno este año lo
hizo en menos de 24 horas así que ya sea
dar el alivio para los campesinos que
fueron víctimas de las prácticas de
china o creando nuevos tratos
comerciales o apoyando las víctimas del
cobi 19 tenemos a un presidente y un
vicepresidente que hacen lo que hay que
hacer y es por el presidente camps y por
su liderazgo que nuestro país ahora
puede volver
crecer la oportunidad esta es una
administración de acción y de resultados
que están cumpliendo todos los días en
su promesa de hacer eeuu grande
nuevamente y eso es exactamente por qué
tenemos que reelegir al presidente
donald trump en noviembre gracias y que
dios bendiga a los eeuu de américa